yo it's the bootleg cab show man we got
a special guest in here
nba legend
dancing legend now
also pretty solid uh mc
we got iman shumpert in the building man
welcome what's going on bo first of all
um
i congratulations on dancing with the
stars i
assumed when you got on there
just knowing your background knowing who
your wife is
you had a a a pretty easy path to
victory i just assumed you were the
betting favorite when i saw that you
were a part of the cast i was like yo
there's like a man's got to come with it
because like your girl loki's one of the
hardest dancers of all time you know
what i'm saying yeah oh
i mean yeah i'll take it if that's what
you felt
but but how like like i wish it was
smooth like that what was that like i
mean obviously i didn't even know there
was thirty seasons i thought it was a
thirteen that's crazy it's um
it's a competition show yeah it's not a
i went with the
the assumption that i was going to go in
here and have a ball and just it was
going to be fun
yeah let me be dancing for a couple
hours
and it's uh
it's
pretty hectic after a while um
i don't know it was like i i damned and
didn't want to do it you know what i
mean like it's like this is more work
than i thought you just get exhausted
with doing every dance that you don't
know you know what i'm saying like it's
one thing to
you know
be a kid and learn how to walk once man
but it's like if somebody tried to teach
you how to walk 10 different ways
as a 30 30 year old you're looking at
them like hey bruh this looks better and
feels better so i'm gonna do this like
you know what i mean like that's what
your mind wants to say and it was just
like
all the small technicalities it was just
like to get my habits to break it was so
difficult i i didn't think it was that
difficult and i'm lucky that danny stay
stayed in the practice right uh i mean
rehearsal space with me for as long as
she did because we did get a lot of
practice in but
um
by the time we did get the trophy though
it was worth it so
it was definitely it was definitely
worth it man um was it like a different
type of challenge for you obviously
being a
athlete um coming from
you know being one of the
however many people are in the nba was
it 370 people in the nba something like
that what are the 370 best athletes in
in the in the world when it comes to
basketball to go into the dancing world
like how how much of a different
challenge was it for you
um
it was it was a it's a big adjustment
it's a
i say um
basketball is already kind of like
poetry in motion so to speak like you
have to make smooth movements uh
with your athleticism and i think
that was like my biggest advantage when
um
when the weeks progressed it was like
danny started leaning on you know what i
was good at you know we start doing
lifts we start
uh
uh just doing things every week that we
started calling them moments but it was
like
we would have these moments that you
you feel something you don't really
you're not really just watching the show
like the us thing it was like people
felt that [ __ ] like they felt like we
was really in the movie like we was
really trying to remind them of the
movements um
and play on the tethered version of
ourselves and it was like doing that i
think
really boosted us but the the
the adjustment from basketball to
dancing
i think basketball is already pretty
much like we got to do it is kind of
like dancing right like i'm doing the
wrong button right like yes i'm like
that ain't nothing but a finish over
there right right
[Music]
that footwork is me getting around the
screen you know what i'm saying like
it's similar it's just i gotta
make it fun so i'm like running around
the rehearsal space like okay euro step
here
five six seven eight okay that's you
know what i mean like that's how i was
remembering i'm sitting here telling
myself basketball terminologies that's
the footwork i also feel like like just
as a person like you've always been like
naturally evolved into like the space of
like
art in some way whether it's being an
artist or fashion and i feel like the
dancing [ __ ] you know like i said it
kind of goes hand in hand with all that
[ __ ] um especially considering like
again tiana's the goat you know what i'm
saying like so it doesn't hurt right um
i mean it's that's what i've been doing
my whole life like
if i wouldn't have went to the league i
wasn't gonna sit on my ass like i wasn't
gonna be
you know what i mean if something ever
went wrong with me in my life like you
see people checking out early it's like
if i ever checked out early how dare i
not try you know what i'm saying
everything right as far as
every competition i'm offered to be in
every
um opportunity um
you know what i'm saying available to
take on like why wouldn't i take it on
like when i got to dancing with the
stars call it's like yeah normally worse
by the way
jerry rice was on dancing with the stars
like some of the greatest i mean one
like smith yeah floyd was on there
that's what really threw me off i'm like
floyd was on there i don't even remember
that that's crazy exactly 30 seasons
when i saw that i was like there was 30
how old am i bro and it's like you go
there you watching and i'm they're like
yeah the football players usually do way
better than you guys i'm just like what
other basketball players
had participated in i feel like there
was rick fox
lamar odom
clyde drexla
okay um
[Music]
i just saw rick fox in a movie that i
didn't know he was in recently i
remember which one i was just watching
some movie from like 2000's man
um i have to tell you this
i'm a phoenix suns fan but i i'm also um
you know the suns have been in a
dumpster fire until you know recently um
so from like uh 09 until recently
just whatever team lebron's been on has
been my team
you know outside of the sun you see i
got charles barkley up there
um but uh
i haven't had more
passionate
screaming conversations with other grown
men
uh about
i've had more
of those arguments about your cavaliers
teams
with than anything else in my life i'm
talking i've had screaming matches with
grown men about the cavaliers like
serious business though oh it's serious
like like i'm i'm saying like obviously
you got traded in what 2015 in the
middle of the season right or was that
before he's on about two to the cavs
from the knicks it was that the trade
that when you and jr came over
yep 2014 2020 yeah that season right and
so
i just i just want to go over that that
time period man now that first year was
one of the biggest what-if years ever
and every time i argue with the warriors
fan
like this [ __ ] right here
my producer
um
i always just think about like that team
and we always see the meme of like what
the warriors had as their starting five
and who the cavaliers had as their
starting five because kevin love got
injured
kyrie was out but still took it to six
games i think it was matthew de la dova
was starting a point guard i think were
you starting at the three or the four
i think you were starting at the three
tristan thompson mozgov um what do you
remember about that series
that you know a lot of people had said
lebron probably should have still won
the finals mvp obviously iggy ended up
winning it but that was such a a
hard-fought series man like what was
that like kind of coming from the knicks
from like
you know a team that probably fell short
of a lot of people's expectations and
then just going straight to the finals
that first year what was that what was
that experience like man
um
would you mean like what do you mean
instead of going
i mean like
you you get traded and then that first
year you're in the finals
oh well make no mistake phil traded us
and wasn't supposed to trade us so
we'd have been cool over there new york
joe like we still would award some [ __ ]
after a while we just wasn't together
long enough they
broke us up phil i don't know what you
was doing phil but that was incorrect
um
yeah phil jackson kind of [ __ ] the
knicks up for a few years yeah shout out
to you for that bro
um
but uh
when we got over there like it took us
it took us just a quick second to like
be able to really like go to war with
each other and practice i feel like
right
when we first got over there we were
still banged up i was still coming off a
shoulder injury
i dislocated my shoulder i hadn't been
playing
so when we got traded uh
just jr was playing but he was like
nursing something as well like we was
just coming over everything was just
sort of random i don't think he like did
much his first game
and then um
once we got into
incident practices
we had some special practices that team
like
uh
i don't know like before we got when we
first showed up like before i started
practicing i just remember coming in
practice and being like bro this is too
smooth like
y'all have no beef like there's no
hectic there's nothing like there's
nothing to push y'all at all
and um
that's what me
j.r and mozzie that's what we was like
that's what we own there because y'all
got
kyrie katie i mean uh lebron uh k love
and brian so it's like
it ain't like it's gonna be many
basketballs being passed around you know
i'm saying too crazy um so
we just sort of brought like a toughness
and a swag and a fun you know what i'm
saying like i feel like damn near they
was scared to celebrate uh three-pointer
you know what i'm saying like you watch
them they was just like regular like
yeah yeah good job yeah it was just like
great guys like yeah no good good play
like
and then when we got there we was just
like yeah we don't do we brought some
swag yeah we just uh like yeah we coming
from new york we just
you know what i'm saying like we're used
to giving that showman like our crowd
like that [ __ ] like we like we we point
at the crowd and start talking [ __ ] new
york love that [ __ ] i'm like y'all just
gonna have to get with it over here like
i don't know what y'all got going on but
we not doing this quietly like that's
what we brought to the team but it was
like marching through that and seeing
brian
um like once we lost ky and he had his
knee
um
because quiet is kept bro
when that this shot came off in game one
if i throw that mod back in it's a
different series because cod never
halves his knee
you know what i'm saying like kyrie
plays that was serious that went into
overtime no he did play that suit no i'm
saying but if he plays that full series
oh that's what i'm saying if he plays
the full series i think you guys went if
i hit that and then basketball is
different forever
because y'all wouldn't be running around
shooting all these threes my man
wouldn't be over here shaking his head
all confidently with this golden state
[ __ ] k.d probably come over there and
play with us as opposed to them because
we want
you know what i'm saying
see what he did you see what i did that
man
katie would have been like day one over
there we figured out we're gonna go over
here shake with them me and brian from
the play together and y'all finna be mad
but that would have ruined basketball
too so i can't either way it ruined
basketball
no he didn't it wasn't katie it was
braun first going to miami broad notes
he wrote basketball okay let me ask you
this do you think that was i always look
at the first basketball he thought he
was he thought he was making it better i
get him so you think lebron ruined it
for everything he ruined the the the
disrespe
me personally i love the nba for the
loyalty that i thought was there
he basically knocked the fourth wall
down like man the owners ain't [ __ ] they
bullshitting we're doing what we want
great business move for sure but
when you think about it outside looking
in like i got people tweeting me right
now they like literally talking about
owners and trades it's like bro y'all
i'm not supposed to be talking about
none of that right actually y'all really
supposed to be going super crazy
if you're a businessman and you sitting
outside looking at you like damn the
fans are supposed to be worried about
the games they're supposed to be talking
[ __ ] like they used to be we used to
just sit there and talk [ __ ] like of
course
i don't care you're not gonna i was a
bullish fan you're not allowed to talk
[ __ ] about judd bushler
shout out to jed butcher also a great
volleyball player
like you're not allowed to talk [ __ ]
about jason caffey none of my guys jason
kennedy or or what was the other guy's
name uh randy brown randy brown you know
you know what i'm saying i went to
school with his son randy brown shout
out to him we could go down the random
boat bill wentington but i'm just yeah
i'm not playing about the bulls and it's
like i feel like now
because everybody's teaming up and [ __ ]
like you'll hear people like no yeah man
but they suck you know what i'm saying
he needs to go over here he needs to get
traded
i'll be listening to this [ __ ] like bro
i'm like do y'all realize the players
that y'all just willing to just
if they don't win this year like y'all
he get traded there he can't win this
year and now y'all just done i'm like
bro these two these two playing styles
is going to take at least three years to
figure each other out before y'all even
got a shot y'all big and y'all small
gonna have to play together for a little
while become like an arms race though
right it's like very much like it's
gonna happen fast it has to happen
immediately or else it's like
everybody's on the high seas yeah
everybody's tweaking it it'd be like bro
they lost three games like road chill
out yeah 82 games somebody lose three
they start caring about what the man
wearing is he coming like it's just all
type of frantic and i feel like all the
franticness happened
when braun went to miami that's when
everything became so critical i guess i
agree with you in that aspect that
things changed as far as people oh no no
i'm not talking about the development of
the game if you watch people how they
scoring today i just mean like the way
the fans perceive the game yeah they
look at it like it don't mean much
because i always look at the first
super team from that era being when
ray allen and kg went to the celtics and
won that first year but that's not
that's not lebron james it's still not
lebron james or dwyane wade for that
matter like y'all got to do that because
that was even like kind of end of kg
peak still pkg but kind of towards the
end
you know peak d wade peak lebron p chris
bosh i mean i i i i guess i get it but
no you don't get it nobody gets it i
hear what you're i i think that it
changed i think when lebron went to the
heat it definitely changed he wasn't
supposed to do that the way fans looked
at
the way we they really started looking
at it like it just don't mean nothing
like loyalty means nothing so when you
talked about the knicks earlier um and
how phil because everyone he ruined it
phil was as great of a coach as he was
was probably one of the worst basketball
people but it's because basketball is in
this hot seat mode so if we not winning
and he on the hot seat he'd think oh i
got to shift it and i got to do this and
it's like goofy no he wasn't you you
ain't like all balls well you got
drafted in 2011
which was a crazy draft
uh that was kyrie
uh kawhi
a lot of players were there jamar jimmy
butler kimba wasn't coming in morris
twins campbell yeah the morris alec
burks
yeah burks is a great player uh vucevic
was in that draft of his uh yeah um
who else was in there that's a hell of a
draft jemmer for dead
jimmer
shout out to jimmer man
he should have yeah but no um when you
go to the knicks
melo's there
you got a great young nucleus yourself
j.r smith um yeah he just took too long
took too long to win man
amari had signed in what 2010 so by the
time you got that because amari that
first year with the knicks really had
like a mvp type season
but then i think after that the injuries
kind of caught up to him
um but do you think that that's what
happened with the knicks like had you
guys stuck around and jailed a little
bit longer
like i felt like when we
after we went to this to the second
round and lost to indy which we
shouldn't have lost that i feel like
i keep my comments to myself on that
well that's what that's the uh paul
george roy hebert lance stevenson team
yeah
keep my comments myself don't keep it
you should have won we should've won
okay
how many games how many games did that
series go six six okay should have won
and
coming off of that
i'll never forget working out doing all
this other stuff and we getting ready to
report back
novak gets traded
and i'm like
what the [ __ ]
what once novak got traded it was just
like what are we doing like
why do y'all continue to
like it's like it just seemed like we're
just doing stuff to our team to just
just to do it yeah like because novak
was like i didn't knock down shooter
good role player but it was perfect for
our ball club right like a perfect fit
yeah i could drive right whenever i want
because nobody's going to help off
nobody right i'm going to dunk this
anybody got an issue with it like
bring your man over here novak that
counts for three you need to count by
two account by three yeah if that's how
pick your poison but we all knew each
other we had a vibe of energy together
and then it was like yeah nobody's gone
uh meet andre bagnani and it was like
now we and we got drea just in an
uncomfortable position
because he's like if he don't jail now
it's like
why we trade for you you know what i'm
saying so now it's like a weird energy
on him also but it's really because we
just miss our dog also too barnyani was
like in a weird position too because
that was like if he if it didn't work
for him there he's definitely a bust
like [ __ ] you know what i mean and then
he was you know saying nervous with the
injury stuff it's just
it was just a lot happening that it was
just like bro we had a nice thing going
and i didn't understand why i got
tampered with but
who am i bro how
well i'm trying you you were there
during the insanity [ __ ] right
what was um
because i feel like that was like a
really
one of the more
awesome random things that have happened
like in basketball in a long time where
you like think of this guy who just
he went to harvard right
he went to like like ivy league school i
think he went to harvard he went to one
of those harbor or yeah he went to
harvard
hitman landed you went to harbor
or is it hot shammy with the harvard gym
no no landry fields oh landry fields
huh wichita state she said
landry fields
no he didn't
i don't know
yeah larry fields um but
obviously mello's out when the the
linsanity thing you know
gets crazy
he comes back
was there like a
weird dynamic within the team when mello
came back like with the insanity [ __ ]
just kind of starting to tail off
what do you mean was it a weird word
because obviously
when that when that started like mellow
was out with a was out with an injury
right yeah he pulled his groin though it
was like a week it was a week okay okay
i just remember that like like if you
watch the sports shows that's what i'm
saying about the sports shows like yeah
you got the media now
doing all that it's like i guess that's
what i'm asking was there a weird energy
when mello came back or was it mello was
happy as hell and he was super happy
that he like bro i could finally rest
y'all win it
mello wasn't even healthy when he first
came because it was a lockout year so
it's like when mello got hurt it was
like he putting this on his back
stat in and out the lineup
mellow really got us on his back playing
40 minutes in november
you know i'm saying like to where it's
like i didn't understand it back then
but it's like bro the vets ain't
supposed to be that heavy on they needs
right now like right right we're
supposed to wait till we get to the meat
and potatoes of the season we think
that's that's what everyone would always
get on lebron about that like in the
beginning of the season he might take
some possessions off or he might you
know what i mean like but it's like yo
it's the end of the season is what
matters right
hey man especially if you're a
vegetarian mellow is dealing with that
type stuff and then
he set out and he was happy because he
actually got some rest he actually had
some real like when he came back the
issue was never with
uh jaylin
he was bumping heads with dan tony
the style that jalen needed
was
basically putting melo in a messed up
spot because he's like i'm kind of
you putting us in something that i'm i'm
sort of like ruining his possessions
that time
because i you know what i'm saying we're
playing two totally different games but
you're trying to put us on the court at
the same time like it's not it's not
working out like mello's thing was when
that man come in when we need him to for
a stretch to do x y and z let's
offense this way right and then give me
a break right here and then you know
what i'm saying and it was like they
just weren't i don't know if mello
seemed to control her because mello
usually don't say much to a coach
but yeah dan tony from what i understand
like i you know again i'm a sons fan so
seven seconds or less era
you know exactly which is why it was
like mellow understood like this is what
you like like jay lynn coming quick
decisions happening but he's like gee
i'm just not
you're not that guy yeah i'm not carmelo
from the nuggets right that's trying to
one foot on the breakaway all day long
like like it's a lockout year you know
what i'm saying let me pick my spots get
in my rhythm so that when we do enter
the playoffs i'm ready to go like like i
got to be in my bag and he like we're
not playing at this tempo during the
playoffs you know what i'm saying like
that's how he felt
like when they when they started bumping
heads it was like
yeah media is going crazy everybody's
tweaking oh we need to make all these
changes and [ __ ] and it's like in all
actuality bro we playing the game like
every other day me and jay lynn don't
know [ __ ] we just winging it
you know what i'm saying i'm like bro i
had a a good rookie season
strictly based off me loving basketball
and just being like [ __ ] the other side
you know what i'm saying like that's the
only reason because you finished like i
think top five in rookie of the year
voting right i just i tore my knee up if
i would have tore my knee up i had i
wouldn't have thrown my knee up and had
a good playoff stance like yeah i would
have felt way better going into my
second year but it was like literally
every year in the summer i had to get
some sort of surgery we always think i
took i think i took i had two years in
the league where i didn't get a surgery
in the summer yeah you had a lot of i
feel like annoying injuries were always
kind of like a thing that plagued you
throughout your you know your you know
they ain't plagued me that's just that's
just basketball right well it ain't
basketball because they don't do it
that's like how i got paid because it's
like
for some reason they act like they can't
run through a screen and deal with
whatever come with it and it was like i
never really cared i'm like
charge it to the game bro that's war you
know what i'm saying like that's how i
be feeling about it like yeah
i'm limping the next day and [ __ ] but
it's just like charge it bro
you know what i'm saying i just be
looking around
the league and seeing like when guys die
on screens uh
they chasing the guy down it's like bro
you know you're supposed to dive on that
but they just don't want to do it just
in case they was to get hurt because
they can in the game they could i don't
seem like that in the game they could
remember like ah don't do that you get
hurt gotta finish with 15 points and
like bro i can't remember that in the
game
i have no clue how many points i have i
have no i don't care like the ball
laying there i'm not trying to i'm
diving on it and i'd love for us to run
into each other so you're saying that's
like a conscious thing that players will
there's a lot of people who recognize
hey look we don't go after these kind of
balls because it can [ __ ] up the bag
i've had guys tell me iman stop doing
that
why are you going why are you doing that
like what are you doing i'm like bro
it's a loose ball hey like
damn you have no chance at that rock i'm
like bro in the middle of the game
though like it's gonna tell you yeah
you're not gonna stop it like in the
championship you're gonna go for it too
of course you know what i'm saying it's
like gee i think i could get to that
like that's how i be feeling i think i
can get to it right so i'm gonna try it
you know what i'm saying i'm a [ __ ] it
and
i think a lot of times like yeah i would
get hurt and they'll literally be like
bro just sit your ass down like you
ain't even have to do that like you ran
through that screen now you sitting out
for two games right like why do you keep
doing that and i'm just like gee like
sometimes i be feeling like this is the
three that's gonna decide the game like
i don't know why i'm like that but i
just am like right he can't have it i
don't want him to have it
or
it'd be some [ __ ] where it's like when i
messed my wrist up he was literally just
getting ready for the season and i'm i'm
dunking too hard but it's like bro i
want it bad like
i want it real bad i can't i don't have
that presence of mine to be like oh lay
this up because you could
mess your wrist up on the rim it's like
brought undunked this a million times as
hard as i could and never messed up my
wrist today i messed up my wrist like
that's crazy man little stuff like that
but that's you got to charge it to the
game man life ain't so i feel like you
had a great career though i mean
obviously i feel like
when we look back at
you know at least my favorite
memories in basketball the last decade
you're a part of those you know i'm part
of a lot of history now yeah man yeah a
lot of history whether they let me back
in or not i'm part of a lot what was
that was there was there like any sort
of serious like
i mean obviously it's basketball so i'm
using the word hatred sports hatred but
was it like what was like the disdain
you guys had for the warriors during
those years
oh yeah we didn't [ __ ] with them
i didn't like them
uh
i'm a huge fan
of all of them now though it's crazy uh
like we had this thing it's like you
hate to play against draymond but like
it's really hard not to like dude
speak with his chest
say what he feel passionate about the
game
he come on the court not to like you
like
he's the kind of guy who you hate but
you would love if he was on if he was
that if he on your team thought we gonna
be the best of friends but it's like he
want to go to war he don't want to play
like he's one of the guys that's like
running through screens
basketball he's doing what i like like
he one of those guys he's a blind guy a
glue guy like
you need him around you know what i'm
saying you need his voice around his
whatever like
clay another guy keep his head down he
gonna shoot it
i loved playing against clay because
clay is one of the only people like i
don't got in my battles with kyle korver
jj reddick all of them push off get mad
i'm all over them roughing them up
talking [ __ ] to them you know what i'm
saying
klay thompson
does not complain the refs like he's not
gonna do the oh ref look at him he ah
man you gravitate clay thompson you
holding him that man goes
chop your wrist down so fast and i was
like bro i love this young light skinned
brother man
this dude don't care man he willing to
fight me
like that's how i felt about clay i'm
like clay is willing to fight me bro
just to get off this screen he doesn't
care he looked dead at the ref and
pushed me off like
hands to my neck push
i'm gonna fall back like this they don't
call
foul and clay just ran down the court
like he didn't give a [ __ ] like and i
was like dawg i love these dudes i just
hate them for now i hate them yeah it
felt like um because you got to keep
seeing them and it just felt like a
serious like
i mean one of the more i feel like the
probably the most serious basketball
beef beef that we've seen
since the 90s it was
it's two different styles yeah and we
kind of knew we all knew like
whoever wins the most of this this
little
war we got going on whoever wins the
most chips basketball is headed in that
style
that's what was scary about like we knew
it meant more because we like bro like
the kids are going to either continue to
go to the post and want to shoot
fadeaways
well they gonna think this [ __ ] okay
they're shooting this [ __ ] from half
course [ __ ] like we was talking no
we've been talking about this [ __ ] like
i remember being switched like man he
want to shoot that [ __ ] before he let
him shoot that [ __ ] for 40. [ __ ] him
like that's the conversation being so
i'm going to come
hey switch man [ __ ] you want to shoot
that [ __ ] from 40 let him shoot that
[ __ ] from 40 dog shoot that all night
[ __ ] like that's what we that's how i'm
feeling when i'm really on the court
like go ahead let him bro i wish you
would pull it put pull that bro please
but we can run this down y'all throw
like please shoot that yeah that's how
we felt about it until this little
[ __ ] started making it yeah but
it's like once he started making it now
t lu looking at us at the drawing board
like hey y'all gonna get out there so
what we gonna do
you shocked yeah you shocked me making
it now like it got it got to that point
it's like bro
when i think about it now i'm just like
bro
i don't i i keep saying basketball
changed
like they ruined it type of thing but
i'm like you ruined the version that i
like
i just feel like it's just it's just the
version i like i mean you really when
you really think about it pound for
pound yeah how basketball it is today
it's scary how good they are
this is true i feel like there's more
good players now than ever as far as
like skilled skilled or just like
skilled all-star basically literally
weeded out
the other stuff like the blended stuff
like if you think about some of the guys
that used to make all-star teams there
was guys that used to make all-star
teams in the 90s that you'd like you
like look back at some of the all-star
rosters in like early like 90s and
you'll be like yo he made an all-star
team like
now it's like the people who wait
what are you talking about i mean like
sometimes you like like like like i'm
not someone i'm someone like early 90s
like i think i saw um
terry cummings is on an all-star team uh
there's
there's just players that you think like
now you can make an all-star team out of
like the top 15 guys that didn't make
the all-star team
and i feel like oh i see what you
understand what i'm saying copy copy
copy um
like now it's like the the
the the guys who aren't making all-star
teams can be done would have been like
can beat the all you could put a team
yeah it's like insane like
basketball has changed from
um
like it's not so much that chess board
anymore
it's checkers it's not greg popovich
anymore no it's not just it's checking
it's checkers it's king me it is this is
the most it's the arms race it's kings
me right
but it's it's the reason why i say that
is because there's literally no thought
involved like
damian lillard is going to come down
here full speed and jump and just shoot
yeah he's going to shoot a 40-footer if
you step up that means he's going to the
basket all the way to the basket but
this is not a foot race immediately if
he can't get it it's to cj and it's the
same thing immediate action like
i think that the if you go look at older
games you go watch the game in the 80s
they sprint the ball up the sideline
they throw the ball to the corner to
flatten the defense they throw it back
up and then they throw it into the post
yeah you go to the 90s they took that
same formula except they threw a shooter
into the corner
and then tossed it straight down to the
post and the post didn't have to be a
big man
but it's all to [ __ ] up the rotations of
the defense right
now
the [ __ ] up is they bring in a ball
screen
they're not even going to the corner to
flatten the defense or throw it in
they're keeping you way out
so it's like when the game changing
dynamic like that when you're watching
this [ __ ]
i don't know how other people process it
but like i didn't had to sit there and
like watch you know i played i got to
play the whoever the best player is so i
get a lot of this
watching how they coming down and being
like bro their point of attack yeah you
were kind of the guy who defended the
best player on the other hand how to
deal with that right that was what you
saw i'm looking at every scheme like
i'm like bro like i've literally made it
to like you gotta think my first year in
the league i had to guard all those
in-game possessions so i'm used to at
the end of the game i'm about to have to
go to the post and deal with so much
contact and
drops and back doors and [ __ ] that i got
to deal with in this mode and it was
like
also when you got drafted that wasn't
the best like you were probably the best
defensive like at least one of the best
defensive players on that knicks team
like
not not
no you could do it they were they
weren't great i mean you know you could
do it if you want to you know
yeah at the end of the game when they go
down you had to pick up a lot of slack
is what i'm saying i mean i had to pick
up slack it's just
it's one of them moves like when you get
to the nba you start realizing these
grown-ass men this ain't
oh man mellow doesn't know how to guard
people is nah fan iman you guard him i'm
finna score 40. yeah
that's this grow man [ __ ] this is jr
literally a come out there and be like
tape i don't
rook handle that i'm not chasing him
i don't care what the i don't care what
the
the plays
you know the assignments and i don't
care you tired look guard him i'm tired
i don't feel like guarding him that's
what j.r say and then like alright cool
that was my job like what you tired what
stat died on the screen and i had to
guard the four man that's when they
first realized i started doing the strip
he would die yeah he would die on a lot
of screens but that's when they were as
a sons fan
one of the more frustrating guys to love
is but that's why i'm married sonia is
on my t-shirt right now that's why i
come in that's what i'm saying bro i
come that's why they like playing with
me though cause it was like how he
didn't average more rebounds it was just
the most frustrating [ __ ] ever as a fan
what are you talking about the sun yeah
i'm like bro you should have 12 12 a
game you gotta miss eight nine y'all
wasn't missing much so he ain't got no
offensive rebounds all defensive
rebounds um let me ask you about this
it's crazy dawg people really don't be
thinking it through like think about it
snap would have had 15 to 20 rebounds a
game but steve nash had them winning and
scoring that [ __ ]
that ball was going defensively
defensively yeah he gonna corral some
rebounds
offensively ain't no tapping it back in
nothing it's water on the other side um
wait hold on time to stop the interview
because we got to talk about our good
folks at odd socks man listen if you go
to
oddssoxofficial.com that's
oddsoxofficial.com
use the keyword keyword it's a [ __ ]
promo code use the [ __ ] promo code
bootleg kev all right at checkout you'll
save 20 off they got i mean look at
these spongebob joints
man the ninja turtle boys you know what
i'm saying how about the naruto guys
and then they got the new odd socks
basics that are just like
they're just so fly man the tie-dye
joints they just listen man
whatever you need they got it how about
some half-baked boys you know what i'm
saying listen
the most comfortable socks the most
affordable socks the best socks in the
world odd socks so go to
oddssocksofficial.com use that keyword
it's not a keyword it's a [ __ ] promo
code
[ __ ]
bootleg cab at checkout save 20 off man
shout out to our family at odd socks if
you support us go support them was it
was it like always you know i feel like
kyrie cooked steph in the most important
moments in those series um
did you guys look at him as like a like
like
yo this is a target we got to get kyrie
switched on the stuff like was kyrie
like always like
when the secret because i remember when
kyrie got like that last shot that in in
2016 like when
kyrie had steph switched onto him he had
that look in his eyes like this is
oh we was talking some of that [ __ ]
it uh
those was one of um
that time
that we had for that was uh
i can't remember what game it was
came off a screen
and steph didn't even try
and kai
i believe he came he re-screened it
because it was like a dummy screen
and he re-screened it which steph's
supposed to immediately fight to switch
back
and i'll never forget steph going with
the roller
like he like made it his business that
he was not guarding cop
and we all kind of like looked around
like
you know what i'm saying like what is
what scheme is that what are they doing
so braun braun never lets you off the
hook if he sees them he gonna exploit it
i want to say we did the same play the
next time they switched again and then
braun called the next time out
and
basically told t lue all bets off he has
to guard him he don't want to guard him
well by the end of that game you could
watch stuff on the screen like
like
like it was i have never seen that he'd
want no part of it i have never seen him
he wanted no smoke yeah he didn't he
didn't draw the line
until like game six game six he drew the
line he was like y'all not finna keep
doing it yeah he started like slapping
the floor type [ __ ] like nah [ __ ] that
come on yeah like now y'all just
disrespected me like y'all not gonna
pick on me like i'm a little kid but for
a second though it was like
because i had never seen somebody do
that unless it's like you got five
thousand you can't touch somebody like
mm-hmm that's one thing yeah that's one
thing you're protecting yourself so he
had like two fouls and he's just like
the fourth quarter and he like yo
somebody come get you know what i'm
saying like you could tell he just was
like man bro i i don't know what to do
with him and we need to stop right now
so he just wanted somebody else on him
but then when we started picking on him
like you he starts seeing like every
thing is for like either you're guarding
kyrie or you're guarding lebron this
play but you're gonna play defense
you're not you're not gonna have no legs
for the rest of this series that's what
we was on and then with clay it was just
like i was just trying to beat him up as
best i could yeah clay you guys got to
do what you can do right man it was like
we're just going to keep on
pressing that clay and keep on doing as
much sprinting sidelines as we can to
keep him
dealing with back doors and having to
stay disciplined and then
with steph curry you're now going to
guard lebron like you're going to use
your turbo every possession on defense
what do you think um
is the biggest misconception about
lebron james for someone who's been in
the trenches with him he's my favorite
player ever so like you know i i kind of
feel like he gets a lot of um
he lost in the finals
that's that's why people have that
stigma of him
he is undeniably
like when you on paper this is the best
athlete
i don't think we've seen a better one
that can speak in public
uh be great with his family give us a
great
you know what i'm saying like
performance performance every night he's
never involved in no [ __ ] he's not
gonna get drunk the night before and
have a terrible game or something he's
not gonna give us uh um
some like dirty plays like the worst
thing we had against lebron was like bro
why are you flopping and literally he
started flopping because he like bro
i got to get these free throws if these
people getting free throws like bro i'm
really getting hit so he's like i'll
sell it for you since they can't see it
cuz i'm so strong right y'all can't see
me getting fouled so i gotta go like
this to show y'all he just raked my arm
but it's like
besides that bro ron has gone out here
every night and played hard you know of
course he gonna have his times he'd take
off for a day or two whatever i get it
you get tired but
i don't know who's been more faithful to
their just being disciplined to the game
like
braun
knows every scheme knows every coach
knows every player he knows players in
college you know what i'm saying like we
talking about [ __ ] like this
he's put together an amazing body of
work i'd say the misconception with him
is that them losses came
from a lack of what he's capable of and
it's not it's uh
i think his losses is just his style
that's just how it goes because braun
plays it the right way at the end of the
game when mike says i don't give a [ __ ]
what happens i'm shooting this shot
braun says i'm gonna get to this spot
and shoot but if i get here and any one
of them is flinching off of their man
i'm beaming it to that man
and he'll be
and to be fair i mean look mike also
john paxton and steve kerr and you know
there's there was times where he did the
same thing so oh okay i thought he was
gonna say he's like you know mike did
that no i'm saying that there there
there was time no no there was times
where he also you know
at the end of very important games
found the open man talking about steve
kerr john paxton you know those but i
think um
i also
i think of the luck of the draw too like
if you just think of like
what lebron had to go through all those
years i always hear people say well the
east was like a cakewalk right like and
i i disagree
as far as you know your guys's passed to
the finals those years
it was just we was just a
it was a juggernaut team so it was like
yeah it looked like the east was like
that because
we was running through it but the east
wasn't easy right but i just think like
just the the the warriors
uh
before the warriors became the lit team
it's not even it's not anybody
i think like
the warriors had to go get kevin durant
to
to to [ __ ] with y'all for sure period
because well no they didn't have to they
didn't have to because
they needed it to like to feel superior
yes and to me that is like yo like you
you know i think the 2016 green is
probably the hardest ring i've ever seen
won yeah it's probably the most
meaningful championship at least in my
lifetime oh yeah i'm being honest oh
yeah i mean you guys beat the 73 and
nine warriors don't and no one ever even
gives a like that regular season didn't
mean [ __ ] because they didn't win the
ring
this is true
and i almost feel like
the the two rings after that like what
what did you want like i mean that was
four all-stars starting on the other
side of that i mean but you gotta
remember
at one point people were saying steph
was gonna be out the lead
like he had bad ankles i remember when
early on yeah
they was talking [ __ ] about this man
when he was winning all this [ __ ] he was
mvp that man was on a 40 million dollar
contract bro it's crazy
they was done with him
and this is the [ __ ] that be like this
is why
i got over them all playing together
cause i'm like bro no [ __ ] i
remember when they used to talk [ __ ]
about steph curry or klay thompson well
those guys the core group they all
drafted which is the one thing i can
never take away from the warriors that's
what i'm saying so it's hard it's hard
to say they got four all-stars they just
it's just the kd [ __ ] man they was just
whooping ass like and became awesome
like draymond green was one of them guys
that people
quote-unquote say isn't an all-star but
it's like bro he mean that much to them
yeah we knew in game five when that man
didn't play we saw how different they
was i'm like bro
no i won game five game six
if he plays game six do you guys think
you still win the ring it'd be tough
they're a different ball club when they
were
there was uh
like
it was like no [ __ ] it was like
coming up to the park and beating up on
some kids and they big brother just
ain't there right now
that's what it felt like it felt like we
just came up to the park and busted our
last and y'all big homie wasn't here and
we beat y'all ass like we just beat
y'all ass y'all ain't do [ __ ] about it
now y'all now y'all calling dude he got
to come back up to the park i love this
next game i [ __ ] hated the war bro
the disdain for the warriors that i have
and then we were at game six like you
saw the like concern and they faced they
was like man we do not want to go back
to go to state dealing with these people
because now they were just looking like
they was just defeated and now they look
like blood thirsty for a win like they
kind of felt the energy but
the cool thing about that whole [ __ ]
like
i don't think we would have
known that like draymond
what did he do hit brawn in the ball
yeah he kept flinging his leg like it's
crazy everything happened for a reason
because it's like bro we would have
never picked out how important draymond
was well also if we do that if we do the
what if game
kyrie is healthy in 2014 2015 you guys
probably have that ring as well yeah if
we're playing the what-if game and then
katie would have came into the cast
oh shout out to kevin durant i met him
with look he i know k gonna be over for
this i gotta listen i gotta shout out to
katie because
i have been uh uh
kd at a certain point in time was i i
really liked the thunder when they were
young and then
i was i i as a fan this is fan hate i
definitely had a lot of fan hate for him
when he went to the warriors
everybody
and me and freddie gibbs went over to
his crib uh last year and he was the
nicest dude ever
i had a rex chapman throwback son's
jersey on we talked about my journey he
was the nicest dude so i had to call my
homies and be like yo man but ann k's
not kate's not sensitive
are we sure
he's got the burner he might be
sensitive to the general public and [ __ ]
right
you know what i'm saying i ain't got
nothing to do with that i'm not general
pop
you fail you i'm not jim pop
oh i ain't got nothing to do with that
like if you want to be awkward over
twitter and you got fenced
you know i just found out what fence to
is so i thought it was a different app i
don't know what that is what is it is
you having a fake instagram it's what kd
has a burner account
but it's all is the i didn't know that
but it's like a whole world of people
that got this [ __ ] up there i'm thinking
that uh
that it's a whole lot what's the thing
yeah this is like a real society why do
people have vince's like it's a real
secret society that you know whatever
but it's like if you do that whatever i
mean when i'm when i'm around cato like
canaan
well he like i said i met him i kicked
it with him it's crazy super nice dude
but um but he's a open dude like you can
say true wow we can have a basketball
conversation and we'd be like hey man
[ __ ] you and he's also like yeah me and
him had like great like i feel like i
had conversation with him like and he
was super open to talking [ __ ] about
hoops
his guard down to be a person it's when
you when you cast him into what he gotta
be and all these others that's when all
of us get uncomfortable well i just
think of the thunder being up 3-1 and
against the warriors and the western
government he's going to join him after
he lost why i don't give just hurt my
soul
now you guys
are
i feel like a gang the cavaliers were
like you guys for the most part the crew
was together
through that whole time right obviously
certain pieces coming and going but when
you guys got the news that katie was
joining the warriors what was that group
chat like
[Music]
that's how i was bro just like because
you know you're gonna have to see them
in the finals i'm like for what that's
what uh that's all we all looking like
huh then we like well what russ got to
say about that's what we all want
russman to say about this [ __ ] this is
crazy
um
but you know as well
that lasted all up until like half the
season once we had already saw them one
time it was like hi bro you you you made
your decision like you got to stay over
there hey
let's beat them like now it's like bump
that i'm glad he over there let's deal
with this like what year did you get
traded from the cavs was it 2018 2019 oh
no bro
did you get it was it from the cavs you
went to the kings y'all gonna have to
google that was it you went 18 it wasn't
18. what trade was that a part of
so i don't even know bro they were just
trying to get me out of there kid at
that point you had to get me up out of
there i had to go it wasn't you know
what i'm saying like
at
some point
it wasn't going to work out with all us
it just wasn't enough basketballs cause
you got to think we don't won
now we're going into the next transition
year
i was already in their ear like hey bro
it's time for me to get the ball back in
my hands like
you know what i mean i'm like i'm 25.
right i don't know
you know what i mean like we got our
ring and [ __ ] i'm like it's time to
groom me back into my point guard [ __ ]
like i played y'all game i ran around
did the three and d [ __ ] i was never a
three and d guy it's like i played but
you you were a two-way player like a
[ __ ] man i feel it i'm a
basketball player everybody in the
league should be a two-way player like a
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying
that should be standard but it's not
which is weird yeah but they was trying
to hype me up like you're a three and d
guy like you can guard people i'm yeah
everybody should be able to do that
that's pride that ain't you know what
i'm saying like that's being a grown-up
i don't know what to [ __ ] tell you
like yes i'll play curry over here yeah
i'll play defense for free bro like i
don't i don't really care like whatever
like it's just part of the game but i
felt like it's time for iman to go back
to playing point guard and when i became
that and i became bullheaded in that it
was like he got to get out of here well
because you were at a certain point in
time you truly don't remember what i got
traded i was gonna say at a certain
point in time you were you were like the
you were running point for the cows like
a bit here and there yeah here and there
yeah i remember that that was the that
was the issue it was like bro
it can't be a tease me type of thing i'm
like kyrie like to shoot that mog anyway
i don't know why y'all forcing him did
you see the kyrie thing festering
because the most surprising thing to me
was when he asked to leave
did you see that coming at all
oh really
but i i've
like we all men like i think people read
into it a little too hard sometimes like
as a man
how you wake up today ain't gonna be the
same as tomorrow you know what i'm
saying it was like
it's stuff that he dealing with talking
directly to ownership that you know a
little pass our pay grade if you're not
the guy on the team right i mean so it's
like
all the stuff that was happening behind
the scenes we didn't know kyrie had been
there longer than anybody you know what
i'm saying
uh
that's a a deeper rooted conversation
for him like we didn't
it didn't really
i didn't see it coming it wasn't a shock
though right i'll say it that way um
i knew kyrie wanted some things to
change just based upon
him being him and being there that long
and it's hard to do that when we don't
know who batman is
kyrie's like y'all going back and forth
with when i'm batman and i don't like it
that's fair yeah i'm saying and that's
what that's what was tough this is like
you got so many people here it's like
even when jr has these moments
that's one of the best heat check
players ever yeah but it's like you got
the moments you got to have the moments
where it's like hey bro i get it i play
with melo i play you know what i'm
saying like i get it also when i was
like the young guy that that shoots the
wild shots and y'all want to talk about
my shot selection and [ __ ] but he like
at some point it's end of the game
that's a 10-year vet throw that [ __ ] in
there and let him play with his back to
the basket right like at some point we
got to activate him to see if he turns
into
what he's supposed to but that's the
issue like they don't do that they'll
just leave you in that role and you got
to play it for 20 years you know what
i'm saying like
that's where players become unhappy
where they're like i'm sitting here like
when you watch your favorite players you
like i watch the development of them
like
you watch a guy come into the league and
then he can't do this or he can't do
that and they put this put this put this
and then it's like now year five they
like all right let's see what he is you
know what i'm saying let's really go for
this title and it's like
you look at it now and it's like can he
do it right now what can you do for us
right now if they don't have it trade
them that's some real [ __ ]
um
talk about you you know what's crazy is
i remember the first time i saw you
rapping
i knew you were like making music but i
saw that cipher with lois and travis
thompson and i forget who else was a
part of that cypher uh
[Music]
who just said you already said lois yeah
it was king lose it was travis thompson
it was you it was
you say cash doll
i'm i'm forgetting somebody
i'll come back to it but it was
i remember seeing it and being like
oh [ __ ]
you always got mistake for designer
but you're a better rapper than designer
uh uh
but now but like you actually like
obviously this is not something that you
just picked up you know because you're
bored like this is something you have
been doing for a long time like kind of
take us back how long have you been
making music or at least playing with
the thought of like rapping or writing
rhymes or just developing that
um
writing rhymes probably since like sixth
grade
making music and developing
what that was
that wasn't till
my freshman year of high school that i
started recording my homie and i wasn't
even like going to a studio my homie had
the uh something at the crib yeah yeah
the the new mac the new uh mac computer
and with that new mac computer they had
that built-in mic
ah yeah learn how to garage van garage
band yup throw the headphones in and
then um
uh he would put the little blanket up to
cancel the noise
and i mean this just still didn't sound
all the way great but uh
we were selling mixtapes like i was in
high school selling mixtapes
um
along with other things but i would
package everything together and get it
out to you
and it was uh yeah it was a it was a
vibe man but
that's when i ate the weed and a mixtape
but it's like i know you gonna listen to
it now but it's like i was doing um mix
cd so i was bootlegging everybody else
[ __ ] bro me too that's how i got my name
bootleg cab literally i was just [ __ ]
[ __ ] burning cds and i had taken
them to the party yeah i had the two
cities all the dual the gangster grill
everything the southern smokes
everything all the g-unit radios i had a
folder
with the
each mixtape cover i just took a little
uh you can find it online yeah print it
out yeah and then put all them shits in
like this binder and [ __ ] no i would go
i do it i would go to and i'd have like
eight versions of the cds stacked on top
of each other right behind that album
and i was taking i literally wasn't even
like you wouldn't even get a cdk
sometimes you just get here's the cd
get a piece of paper i used to go to
office management with all the
with all this all like put that in right
now
like you ain't got no case put it in
right now though
that's so crazy
i used to i used to like go on the
message boards and download all the
mixtapes and [ __ ] and
albums bear [ __ ] yeah
and then uh
i'd hit officemax and buy the slim jewel
cases i had a little bootleg i used to
go shoplift the ink did you get the
color the color coordinated yeah the
cases yeah yeah the yellow but like you
know i had i had like i like i used to
print all the all the covers off yeah my
little cheap-ass printer and i would go
steal the ink because if the ink was
[ __ ] mama expensive
i'd steal the ink cartridges out of the
demo printers at the store and then in
school you can do them and then i
printed it print the covers and then i'd
be at the swap meet every weekend slang
and mix tapes man
and dvds too
man what was you remember what the best
seller was that was me cleaning them up
what's the best seller like like do you
remember which artist or which product
drop out college dropout wow i've never
sold so many of one project for me it
was uh i used i probably i've sold
hundreds of game the documentary album
the documentary did well too the
documentary was moving boy but i was i
was big on mixed cds i always had
at least like 25 requests
well i used to do that too or somebody
would give you a list and i'd be like
cool 20 bucks i'll go make the cd for
you exactly see you was charging way
more i should have charged that much my
kids and my i would charge five bucks
per mix tape at the swap meet five bucks
but if you wanted a custom mix it was a
dub
so if like let's say i should have did
that yeah my custom my custom mix was
like it was like 10 bucks now i'd be
like yo you could get this cause i was
really running them i was really running
them dudes you could get this new dj
drama mixtape or whoever is mixtape uh
but if you want me to put some [ __ ]
together for you it's twenty dollars
yeah but the 20 was really for the you
know what i'm saying for your time party
no your party favorite like it wasn't oh
i see i see
so the twenty was for the eighth that's
what i'm saying like i was born that and
then it was
like now it's 25 balls 30 balls coming
yeah each time we dealing with a
customer you know what i'm saying we
killing two birds one stone but i'm
getting my project out there that's how
i felt about it like i'm getting my
music out there like but what was crazy
was people really was rocking with it
like and at this time you're obviously
a star athlete at school i'm assuming
which is why they took it away from me
they made me stop because i wasn't
back then i didn't know
nobody made it out where i was from
just i'm not where are you from
so i went to that well that's my school
opera forest is my high school okay but
i'm from oak park which is we bought a
kid so if you've got chicago we have a
town inside the city
that's literally says if you cross this
street
you're now out of chicago
but it's chicago like a [ __ ]
right i'm saying but that's the cool
thing about this because i get like
people that be like thinking i'm going
to be like this suburb kid like i look
great on paper you know
oh paper i'm a great city i'm an
outstanding guy and
i think that it's cool as hell when
you talk about the the
dynamic of
selling these cds and getting [ __ ] like
that off because it's like i got
protected in the sense that i got like
the suburb kids the city kids i got
everybody in one because i was a boarder
kid so nobody really knew where i lived
at
people was trying to figure it out like
he all the way down here he go to old
park
his grandma stay right here like it was
like that but it was like my clientele
was just going crazy and then
i'm rapping and i'm freestyling i'm
doing all this and i start realizing
like people are really giving me a
chance to do this but
i'm super flagrant
in my my raps you were seeing some wild
[ __ ] oh yeah cause i'm but i'm talking
about stuff you're doing yeah yeah
i'm talking it like yeah you're talking
about the [ __ ] you're doing in the
streets i'm like bro i can't you know
what i mean and they was like my
coaching them heard it and they like you
want like
just they might use this against you if
you're getting recruited
fair enough immediately yeah like you
have to stop so i basically was like
telling everybody like yo just please
like don't don't upload this [ __ ] yeah
like just trying to keep it as low as
possible like we just like doing like
just what is that pr damage right right
yeah [ __ ] like that's what we trying to
do that
this is why
we try to do the damn we try to do the
damage control but i was just saying
like if you go back and listen to it
you'll be like damn like he really
thought he wasn't going to the nba all
alone the way he was talking on these
rappers wait he talking yeah it's like
wait talking it don't sound like dude
ever played basketball in his life or
give a [ __ ] i play basketball and it was
like um
after that i had to sort of start
tailoring [ __ ] that's why if you go
really listen to my
my earlier like stuff that i released
when i played for the knicks like i
listen to it now and i like cringe and
get mad because i'm like bro none of
these songs was like this
this is a bunch of
take this out take that out can't say
this can't say that so essentially you'd
like like you would have to almost
record a song and then comb through it
afterwards and be like you know what i
i'm i play for the knicks i can't say
this yeah and then have a record then
i'm like man this [ __ ] just this the one
and then i'm like i can't do nothing
with that one though because you can't
say this and then it's like i can't
release it because i would have had to
release it during this time but we play
tomorrow
and now everybody to think i'm not
focused you know there's just so much
[ __ ] if you drop music during the season
people going to look at you crazy yeah
exactly and then it was like because i
was able to stay on beat and everybody
else that it's like playing defense
right dude listen there's historically
so some of the worst rappers ever came
out of that real talk but it's like
because test was horrible god bless him
i went to a ron artest music video shoot
with mike jones and like when i was like
in high school and it was it was rough
true warrior i remember his label true
warrior i was at the video shoot shout
out to shout out to true warrior rex oh
it was the mic
you remember that song
ran our tests at mike jones no oh my god
it was bad but i was at the video shoot
why it was in phoenix i was a kid in
high school they're like ron our test is
shooting a video on the south side where
mike jones we're like we in there what i
swear to god bro why was he in arizona
dude i have no [ __ ] michael jose
no he's from texas that's
and this is peak mike jones
this is like swisher's house
yes
i'm like we're going it was at this
record store called in the groove
records and we were hanging out
mike jones has got he shot the video
inside of the uh
the inside of the store there was a
barber chair and he's like getting his
like fade while he's doing the video and
it's a ron artest so i just looked it up
on youtube recently to see if it was
still there it's still there
terrible
oh it's so it's so bad see that's how i
feel like when i go back and i listen to
it i'm like bro i could tell i'm like
reading
raps not feeling them not
you know that's the thing about music is
my homies ain't in the studio yeah right
now like i could tell what these songs
are and it's like i get it
like even when um like i used to be like
getting mad when my eyes used to be
doing the whole they like man out of the
nba rappers you know i just feel like
you know it's damon online doing all
this other [ __ ] and i used to just be
like i used to low-key be getting
annoyed like because i'm like damn bro i
should have just saved all my music
now yeah even when i see stuff like when
people bring up
the best nba rappers they'll like play a
song that i did when i was in like it
was like 2010 right 2011 type [ __ ]
and they'll play that song about who's
the best nba rapper and i'll be like bro
that's a that's awesome yeah like i'll
be like what's you know what i mean is
this to to pis is this to piss me off
i'm like y'all trying to piss me off
y'all steady starting threads and stuff
so i still think it's y'all playing i
still i still y'all gonna play damn new
[ __ ]
y'all playing i still think it is i was
just saying i still think it's shack
shack
sack with platinum and he had nas and
jay-z on a song together
shaq was playing what's the song i don't
know but you see the name of it but this
is what i mean by about the rapping [ __ ]
like i feel like we all took an l until
somebody's singing our lyrics
that's real like music is about breaking
up stop the rain by shaq man you still
don't know it you can't stop the rain
come on that [ __ ] was i mean that wasn't
his part it was a great hook though
no that's fair i think damien has i
think
tell me about a sampled hook do you
think they start singing do you think
big his part
do you think dame has at least done the
best job of like
juggling both no i think dame is a
superstar athlete with
the money to put behind it i don't think
that i think the nba is way more lenient
with dame doing stuff like letting him
perform for all-star doing all this
which i'm happy for him i'm not hating
i'm just saying
if i was a rock star like if i if i
never played under mello and stat and
when i went to new york it was just my
[ __ ] and we just was i was the rookie
that get to shoot it 30 times and do
whatever the [ __ ] i want right my music
would it it went different because it
was like nba can't say
you might have been kevin knox low-key
no i'm just talking about it that's the
thing i was just playing guaranteed no
sir like i had new york cracking no no
no i mean it's like if we if we gonna
if we gonna
uh
let him shoot 30 shots a game to where
it's like
pressure or not yeah i'm shooting until
i get in the mix like right like in high
school it's like bro whether i'm having
a good stint a bad stint i'm i got the
ball so much i could sort of get in
rhythm you get in a groove you know what
i mean like it was like if i if i had
that
then it's like they would have never hit
me with the oh he's not focused then
it's like if i say a curse word or two
who cares my [ __ ] i'm signing for 100
million like yeah also if you're a human
being people cuss that's why we're
[ __ ] growing up in which i started to
realize once i'm like 27 i'm like bro
[ __ ] y'all i got a daughter like yeah
like i'm not just because i hate it i
graduated from listening to you
[ __ ] yeah it's crazy yeah
that's why i got to that point where i'm
just like bro you think you're like a
better parent because you lie to your
kid all day like they don't close the
door until talk about the real you like
kids know exactly what you're doing bro
it's just whenever you're gonna let them
in on it
so it was like
with me i'm like once i got to that
point where i got daughters it was just
like i'm gonna say what i want and sort
of do what i want that control is kind
of gone but i feel like
it's it's helping my music like it help
people to to connect with me if
they know like dude a lot like me like i
thought he was like this superhero that
never makes a mistake and [ __ ] but it's
like who
honestly bro who's rooting for him
nobody wants to root for dude
this is like goody too soo ass like i'm
not rooting for him i don't like him do
you feel like now um
your music is
in a place to be
you know kind of like the forefront of
your focus as far as like you know
obviously
yeah you got you got past uh
yeah i think uh at this point
it it's gotta be
just the only thing that it's literally
the only thing that can ever be taken
with father time ain't gonna take this
from me mm-hmm she's gonna live on
forever yeah like this father time just
can't take
my voice
you know what i'm saying well father
time can i just i ain't gonna hit that
for a longer time it's gonna be a while
before that happens exactly basketball
athletically i mean everyone has still
yeah i could still go out there and do
everything i need to do and play the
game but it's like
at some point that was gonna stop so
it's like i knew at some point i was
gonna tap more into the art
side of who i am you know what i'm
saying it was just a matter of
everything lining up and i feel like
right now
entertainment wise music it just
is people want to hear me tell my story
that's that's my favorite way to do it
what are the uh mc's artists that are
kind of you know
currently doing their thing right now
that you're that you're actually like a
fan of
there's so much dope hip-hop that's out
right now
i'm a my newest
um
my newest uh i'll say flowers and now my
flowers is joyner lucas joyner's fire
best videos it's the videos in decades
it's the video i'm like
he he reminds me of you know when we
grew up we were watching busta rhymes
and missy elliott and type [ __ ] yeah and
like we know we're gonna or ludacris
remember ludicrous you know what we're
going for them for joining us these
videos are they're so well thought out
they're just amazing you got a great
team and he could wrap his ass off for
sure he got a great team um
but i love that he doesn't hang his hat
on if he has a club hit
a hundred percent it's like i'm gonna
give you content i'm gonna give you
gonna build this organic fan base
conceptually it's dominant and i
i [ __ ] with that
him
dirk is just
he's gotten to a point that um
i truly feel like everything he says is
just chicago like if i want to go home
i'm putting on dirt
you know i'm saying i'm putting on her
because just
they've gotten to the point where i no
longer feel like they rap they just sort
of talking
talking for us like
i don't know how to explain it just like
everything they say is sound like they
in a in a chicken spot with me it don't
sound like they rapping and trying to
make a hit song it's like gee whatever
they say is law right now
um
outside of them
j.i.d yeah he's incredible i'm a big jid
fan that's my boy too
shout out to dreamville now jid is uh
quiet his cap like technically one of
the illest like oh dude he can't it's
just it's a lot to digest oh it's a lot
man he's technically just a jedi
i'll never forget hearing that never
been [ __ ] never had [ __ ] never knew [ __ ]
never i would never do [ __ ]
[ __ ] never gave two sits right
his uh yeah his cadence is unbelievable
and then besides that is i'm a little
baby guy
yeah little baby it's great to protect
him at all costs little baby and
and dirks like uh
code zoo well no just the way that each
of them have evolved in front of our
eyes as artists and just as like
you know i think a dark like dirk really
didn't hit his stride until like two
three years ago but he's been in the
game for so long as far as like people
like looking at him as like one of them
ones i think
i went from dirk uh
at some point dirk kind of
figured it out
yeah i want to say it was signed to the
streets too
there was a certain point where you just
were like oh dirk figured this [ __ ] out
cause he had always been you know doing
his thing he was like
forever he was like
doing his thing and he had the streets
and then he like
started trying to like figure out the
mass
and at some point
it was like he got on a record and he
started talking like he was older than
everybody
and i was like
now you win
yeah before he was like it was like real
young boy let me show you my world to me
that's how i took it right and then
at some point on sign to the streets it
was like he graduated himself like
no no i graduated and now i'm trying to
like tell y'all what happened i think
and then i think with little baby i
think little baby might be
probably the most improved mc i've seen
in a long time because if we think about
like early little baby we would think
like little baby would openly talk about
how gunna would like give him tips on
how to rap and like he hasn't been
rapping that long you know and if you
just think of like the last two years
he's like a superior he's like one of
the top-notch like
emcees not just guys who make records
that you could hear in the club or on
the radio like this [ __ ] can rap
circles around
99 of the population i think it's uh
one it's a little bit of this
little baby's energy like
little babies like a uh
well i can't think of like i don't watch
you watch uh like cartoons and [ __ ] yeah
i mean cartoon as somebody that like
like
takes in energy and [ __ ] gosh and then
they have like a big power up i was
going to say dragon ball z
mega man mega man that's that's a video
game
video game but it's like little baby
reminds me of that i can't like he like
it took everyone's powers that he was
around and then just it's type it's not
even that it's the energy of what he's
dealing with yeah so it's like with
little baby
you know how people like get to this
point where it's like you hot you just
drop these two songs like
let's chill let's work these records and
do this right and it's like little baby
has this gift that it's just like nah
let's go again it's like no here's
another project here's a collab
even on his even on his is his his uh
his features it's like it sounds like
like when cali like keep going like i'm
like
it's the energy like how he just gonna
keep that khalid record i'd be like this
the whole time in the car my wife be
like bro oh my god y'all finna play this
little baby this boyfriend lose his man
like that song that's what they always
sound so crazy but it's like dog he
talking low like anybody that's gonna
talk it and and say like it's just like
i don't know like all right my [ __ ] is
that that i ain't got a hundred million
i can't chill yet but don't get in mr
screw you i get real chick he just put
uh he just put 42 doug fell asleep in
the studio and he filled him he's like
how are you falling asleep he don't have
100 million
but it's like stuff like that it's just
the work ethic the the
the forefront of what he's saying um
watching him
force capital on to his people
yeah like he's forcing them to have to
figure it out with money like i'm a i'm
gonna bring in so much money so much
money has to come around every time i
show up that y'all gotta make money
y'all gotta figure it out and i love
that energy like anybody that could push
that like i used to go to meek for that
energy you know what i'm saying like not
to say i'm meat fell off of some [ __ ]
it's just
everything energy's different around
meek yeah every couple of years but i
mean meat's getting older well i was
gonna say that happens yeah me bossing
up to like like i said they graduated
themselves different types of sneakers
been around for 10 years now i mean you
know but that's what meek was when i
first dream chasers dream chasers he's
showing up with a hoodie a hundred
[ __ ] and they rapping and the energy
is just like
you know what i'm saying like i feel
like that's what little baby is but
little babies like the meek energy that
meek had with the hoodies but it's like
everybody got on chains everybody got
home watches
everybody and they all behind him like
with this energy that's just like i've
never seen an energy like that in a
studio like
you know what i'm saying like i've been
around a lot of artists like him and
another person that impressed me in the
studio was young thug i've never seen
two people work that exactly
like yeah i think thug's an alien from
all accounts i've heard no [ __ ] yeah
i heard he's like just no [ __ ] and
like i think i'm talking about i've had
people say in the studio
nobody can hear what he's doing like the
engineer has headphones on he's in the
booth
and you're just going to hear it when he
wants you to hear it yeah yeah but he's
but he's in the other room he's spazzing
the [ __ ] out he's also meticulous like
he's gonna go in there he's gonna do his
thing y'all gonna record whatever then
he gonna come out and he gonna grab the
mouse and he gonna do some stuff himself
and we're seeing the meme like it's
oh yeah people think it's a joke in the
background it's like one of the biggest
greatest memes ever like people be
thinking that's like for food for fun
like it's like that's him he knows
exactly what he's doing he's really in
control he really trying to do something
right now like and it was crazy because
it was like before that a lot of times
when i go you know he does the high
pitch stuff with the autotune
a lot of times i couldn't understand
some of the stuff he said and i i look
he had a knock against thug for that but
being in there and seeing it
and then hearing yeah it's like he's
like going for a certain pitch this is
not a
this is not a he just went in there and
i thought he just went in there hiding
just like yeah just like he didn't
really care that much stop behind it no
he yeah he's really like nah if i get
you to that frequency
and i you know i say it like that
you'll never forget what i said because
it's so unique it's so left it's so
random that it sticks out it's a sore
thumb
and
it doesn't seem beautiful all the time
at first but it's like over and over it
might be the only thing you remember
from the song
yeah i think two people like anytime
someone is so different and so
unique hey man young thug made dropping
jews
that's one of the coldest what i'm
saying is like is like the kind of
artist who comes into the game and is so
unique that like
people are supposed to be like what the
[ __ ] is this for sure i mean he just
threw everybody off with the dresses and
i think that's i think that's any i mean
even even think about little baby like
when little baby first came out people
like what the [ __ ] is this guy saying
like
you know what i mean it's just like
anything that's great is initially gonna
come
you gotta get used to anything new you
know what i mean like if everyone was
just feeding you the status quo all day
everyone would still sound like [ __ ]
run dmc you know what i mean
so
shout out to run dmc
um what uh music wise what do you have
on the on on the uh
on the slate right now um we just
dropped outside so outside was one of
them records that happened
should have been came out but
i just started doing too much i took on
the dancing with the star [ __ ] yeah yeah
film that show like every timing yeah
yeah definitely one
um
but uh
yeah i dropped outside i got the video
coming next we shot the video in chicago
it was nuts yeah you know we probably
came out of honey strong
went out and [ __ ] city up a little bit
like it was it was a good time
but um
[Music]
yeah we're gonna drop that video
and uh i guess going into the new year i
mean i gotta you know i gotta clear what
giant stone to make sure but i i believe
i believe we dropping
just to kick the year off so
this car ain't stolen that's what the
album called what is my
it's my um
my first album that i'm putting out
everything else has been like ep cause
you put ep out yeah little uh little
stuff but that's literally just to
remind people that i still remember
these currents aren't stuck this car
isn't stolen so so i'm assuming that's
something that's happened to you before
being a millionaire who's
african-american probably driving some
of the nicest cars oh yeah yeah yeah
that's like pulled over but it's like a
it's like a dickhard moment though when
you do it like
you pulling me over and you want this
car to be stolen so bad but it's not
it's so clean yeah it's so clean you
want this firearm to be off you won't
you just want so much to be going wrong
right now but nothing's wrong
it's so fair and square i just like i
love that moment of looking at the cops
like what's up bro you know oh you must
yeah that's me bro
that's me yeah i played with bro all
that same dumb [ __ ] but you pulled me
over for some [ __ ] escape yeah yeah
let me out i gotta go all right i really
need to leave sir i do
sir can i have my id back my father's an
insurance agent i know my [ __ ] together
give me my [ __ ] back clock lee cause you
ain't pulling me over for nothing but
it's like playing on that
i've been
slammed on the hood of cars
i've been
patted down for no reason i've had to
deal with all the same similar things as
everybody else being an african-american
man
that stands over six feet right i'm
automatically a threat right if you're a
cop that's not
way bigger than me i i would see myself
as a threat too you know what i'm saying
i'm not saying it's like
it's a bad thing but it's like i've had
to deal with that
so for me
in life
i don't take things as all this is
unfair i'm sad
everything to me is competition so it's
like okay this is a game this is now
monopoly
i win
that's what this album is it's like bro
y'all gave me [ __ ]
i was aboard a kid y'all didn't really
like the suburb kids said i was broke
the city kid said i was a suburb kid and
i was soft
you know what i'm saying y'all said
nobody go to leave from oak park like
i'm like far as i'm concerned i won this
game monopoly like that's how i feel as
far as i'm concerned i won
officer
you know what i'm saying like officer
you just got to get better at the game
of monopoly bro but i didn't tell you to
be an officer you know what i'm saying
you could drive this same car if you
work really hard and put that [ __ ] in
the hoop
you don't say if you put it in the hoop
i swear to god you could be here too you
could do this too bro you're probably
five eight and two hundred ninety nine
ain't got nothing to do with me because
there's some people that's five that's
your parents yeah yeah they got nothing
to do with that not many people that are
five eight that's a couple guys five
eight yeah it's a couple guys man i mean
isaiah's in the g league who else who
else is five foot eight
i mean we got i hate that g league see i
hate that the g league made it possible
for people to say that about isaiah
though i know because god bless him he's
he's in it bro i cannot believe the
violation that the g-league will allow
bro we can't do that that big who oh for
sure that bed was all stopped
candidate
dog gave us 50 after he got terrible
news in the playoffs sister yeah he took
a shot
yeah
just taking shots in the hip so that he
could figure it out i know i was so mad
when the second
people got this man begging to play
basketball well not big but
it is crazy you should not be knocking
on nobody door like yeah man i got more
in the tank like come on bro like that
type of stuff that hurts do you still do
you still feel like i don't knock on
doors do you still feel like you have
some some in the tank
i got more than that yeah
but i'm saying do you have the like do
you still want a lot of people playing
basketball right now in the league over
me that i feel like they should not be
playing ball in the league over me
you know what i'm saying i'm just not
willing to violate i'm not gonna give
y'all specifics and trying to violate
people i mean i could go through the
ultimate i'm my ultimate competitor
everybody that know me in the league
know bro i i want to compete i want war
i want conflict like i love that energy
of basketball i'll tell you who i would
rather have on the sun's i would rather
have you instead of abnormal nader
there's a guy on the sun's
name every time he gets every time i
happen to every time monty williams puts
abnormal nader in the [ __ ] game i
want to stab myself no
but you know what's crazy that's what
i'ma tell you about basketball though
like
i'm able to talk [ __ ] about it because
i'd have played in league yeah yeah yeah
i'm talking [ __ ] as a fan but
the thing that's crazy is you'll put
dude on the court in the right system
and he'll bust people in oh for sure i
mean everyone in the nba is good right
very good yes very good it's just crazy
that you can
like that's what i'm saying before braun
went to miami bro
do you realize i feel like it was not
disrespectful i feel like it was only
hardcore i feel like there was no
disrespect going now i don't know many
ball players like this dog when i was
younger when i was a kid i hated carl
malone so much
i just i i i i would him i hated him too
because him and john
i just thought john stockton was the
corniest short short wearing i'm like
look at this corny ass [ __ ] like
that what made the basketball great
because like you got to come to utah and
guard these short short [ __ ]
that say yeah y'all have to swag we
gonna bust y'all ass when y'all get here
you know i mean that's i i i feel like
hardcore basketball fans are always
talking [ __ ] i don't know for sure you
got to that's what make the game great
bro let me ask you this
do you guys pay attention to
the skip baylesses of the world the
first takes of the world the stephen a
smiths of the world they're part of it
they're part of it it annoys you but you
know i don't think we take it we don't
take it that
some guys do have moments where they
take it pretty personal though but it's
just annoying like you you wake up from
your
pre-game nap and you got a million text
messages about what skip bayless said
about you
before a game because some of that stuff
to me is like borderline like
take it personal type especially like
when we're talking about like you know
the skipping lebron
dynamic or some of the stuff steven a
smith has said about certain people
i'm glad at times i'm glad they don't do
that to me
um
you know you're not sure how you would
take it i'm sure not yeah i'm not sure
how i would
but i'm big on
i'll take it fine publicly yeah like i
can
i can
media coach myself right you could be in
the press conference yes yeah say the
right thing ask me a question i give the
marshawn unless i'm just here so i don't
get fined like whatever
it's when i have to see you again
that's when things can get interesting
yeah like stephen a is a
you shooting around before the game he
come out there hey what's up man just
start talking to you it's like bro if
you ever went on national television
and created a whirlwind with my life
before a basketball game and i didn't
perform how i wanted in that basketball
game if you walked up to me before i
said hi i don't know what'll happen yeah
just because i would react
you know what i'm saying like it would
be literally grown man reaction in the
same way you say when you play
basketball you react to go get the loose
ball yeah you don't think about that
like when you when you talk about
something like that it's like bro i did
everything right with my pre-game my
pre-game routine i was in a vibe we had
a great practice we doing all this stuff
and now randomly
you bringing this up and you and skip
argued about it for an hour and now
everything that everybody is talking
about is just negative stuff with my
name and i can't do anything now i can't
go on instagram if i wanted to look at
something that was posted by
my wife
i can't go on instagram now because as
soon as i open it everybody's talking
about what you and skip was talking
about you know what i'm saying so it's
like if i had to deal with that dynamic
every day
i probably would have an issue with it i
can only imagine i i'm glad i did and i
had to you know i think after a while
everybody sort of realized that hey bro
let's just leave dude out of baby
would you would you um would you try to
get a little off would you try to get
back on a roster or do like the big
three thing at all or
um
[Music]
uh i don't know i i never gonna say no i
love basketball bro like i just like
playing basketball so i wouldn't rule
the big three out big three is always i
love watching the big three i think it's
like playing basketball i like to see
iso joe out there you know what i'm
saying
it's like bro we're gonna play anyway
yeah yeah i try and explain to people
all the time they're like man do i wish
you just it's not like you stopped
playing yeah it's like bro i don't not
love basketball i still play like the
owners of that ball club and the gm is
going a different direction that has
nothing to do with iman like you not
finna like bro if you all want to come
to the gym that i be at like you got to
know somebody right
but it's like dog we be in the gym like
we getting it in right it's just
whether or not
the opportunity is there because i'm
like though
though it's like i'm working my ass off
they can't just be like oh yeah you
might come in they got to make sense
like they got young guys they drafted
they got right right right they got the
g league they got g guys that are
already there that are 22 years old and
healthy right now and under their wing
right it's like me it's hit or miss bro
it honestly is if you you bring it in
well i'm a 10-year veteran right i'm 30
years old i don't come with well you're
not that old i'm 31. i'm i'm just saying
what i'm saying is if you got a 22 year
old
and you wasn't finna give me the ball 20
times of play anyway i mean 20 times a
game anyway why wouldn't you pay the 22
year old do you think cause i think i
think of like a team like the lakers
that have lost a lot of their defensive
credibility this year that's what i'm
saying that's on brown man brian no
brian no one man
bro you know what time it is man that's
all you sure what do you think you know
what time it is that's all you bro you
know who you could call shawty mellow
too they ain't just on bro i lied mello
that's all youtube man if y'all always
heard nothing about y'all uh defensive
issues and
and leadership veteran issues and all i
don't want to hear that out of them too
i was going to ask you like as just from
someone who's close to you know brawn
and mello like you know and also as a
basketball guy what do you think is is
wrong with the lakers this year
[ __ ] some doing an interview with you
right now
that's the issue
she should be with them
no i'm fine uh
now for real for real it it
i was playing but i'm kind of serious
like i really do feel like it's
something that's
i haven't been around the team to know
exactly what it is right but
to me they don't get down together like
i feel like they don't feel like they
hanging out like well i feel like they
traded away a lot of that right because
if you think of like for sure but i mean
i'm
there was a time that during that calf
season that bron literally
ex stretched stressed the importance of
us all hanging out together
like i remember the was it the halloween
party with steph curry always do stuff
was it a steph curry tombstone was that
what it was i forget what it was
it was something like that
it was like a warrior's tombstone or
something or one of the bronze halloween
parties i don't remember i was i was
yeah i don't remember that that's that's
[ __ ] good
but um you see so you you think it's
just the fact that they don't really get
down together like it just i don't think
they got a chance they haven't had a
chance yet you know what i'm saying like
maybe
covey and all this other stuff like it
just doesn't look like a bunch of guys
have been hanging out
and
playing pick up against each other
enough you know what i'm saying it's
like they don't know how to all the way
get each other vibing and that's you
know once you add russell westbrook it
changes a huge thing do you think that
that was uh
do you think that that was the right
decision i don't think that was the
right decision at all i think that they
would have rather have had buddy healed
and kept alex caruso
because that's why it works better it
works better for braun right but
you're also talking about
19 years in braun
yeah
you know what i'm saying so it's like
yeah i saw today that they were saying
that the lakers are it's okay to bring
russ if you got a 19 year in bronze
because it's like russell puts that pace
and if lebron has to sit out two weeks
there's someone who's home
who can hold the fort down let me ask
you this there there's a rumor going
around
um that the lakers are looking into ben
simmons
if you're the lakers gm hypothetically
iman jumper you're the gm we've seen it
happen james jones is the sun's gm he
was in the league not long too long ago
if you could trade russell westbrook for
ben simmons would you make that swap
if i'm the lakers if you're the lakers
you're making this one
that's fair for sure
but that's just me
that's my preference basketball
it's it helps you a lot on on the
defensive liability that's happening
you've got the best perimeter defensive
guy in the in the league becomes great
on defense yeah
it ruins a lot offensively it does it
scares us it scares them but it only
ruins a lot offensively if you're not
willing to take the challenge of what
the challenge is when taking on ben
simmons
the challenge of taking on ben simmons
is
he doesn't shoot threes
but it's not the
we need him to
he just doesn't shoot threes and it's
okay
the moment everybody gets that [ __ ] out
of their mind he's gonna be fine
who gives a [ __ ]
demar don't shoot threes
yeah tomorrow we don't give a [ __ ] but
tomorrow's putting in work right now
but listen to yeah no no but simmons has
been putting in no no you're right
you're right right i just think that
demar offensive ben simmons been putting
in work you're right fool yourself
listen don't fool yourself for what ben
simmons been out here
i think he's been the best defensive
player the last three or four years [ __ ]
the defense bro offensively he's a bit
of a liability though no he's not he
just doesn't shoot the three you know if
he creates some
facing issues if he was six foot two
y'all would not care that he can't shoot
if he was six two
because he's six eight
and he light skin
y'all got an issue with this man are you
saying he looks like a tall steph curry
no yes yeah
that's precisely what i'm saying
that's literally what i'm telling y'all
bro
literally
if this dude was just dark-skinned i
don't think we would care but he is
supposed technically he's supposed to be
able to shoot the three and if i was a
coach i would not give a [ __ ] if this
boy shoots a three i can't believe he
got this far without shooting the three
i wish i could have got that far without
shooting the three bro right right i
wish to death that coaches never turned
me to 3d i hate shooting threes
i've always hated it never liked it felt
like it was soft made me look soft made
me feel soft i didn't feel tough when i
had to shoot hella threes and people was
like why you well you gotta go back to
that mode i'm like bro they took the
ball from me i stand in the corner i
feel light skin i feel like the sun is
not hitting me at all
like that's how i felt you know what i'm
saying i feel like i'm losing my
superpowers standing over here it's just
not the same and i feel like
if the lakers take on being simmons it's
like shorty if you let that man run
point he pushing that tempo
all game now you got him and braun going
back and forth both of them point
forwards you're changing the game that's
twin towers at the pg
we've never seen that
yeah i just think i think ads gotta i
don't know and then you got a.d yeah
give me two shooters and let's go hoot
yeah
what the [ __ ] they just need the
shooters what the [ __ ] is the other side
gonna do they just need the questions
but yeah i would pull the trigger on
that no disrespect and then you would
sign yourself to be a shooter no
disrespect god you know how i get down
with you sweaty
go to war with you against you or
whatever man there's no disrespect to
you but if i'm being a gm boy
i'm getting that ring kid
a couple of quick ones the most
frustrating player you ever had to guard
james harden
he learned how to bend that rule book
the loophole god the best i've ever seen
it done
the best i've ever seen it does he's
like an old white man for texas
yeah
[Music]
he's gonna get the most out of it he's
gonna he's gonna get you in here biggest
return you gonna think you have to spend
a hundred grand in taxes out the window
he's gonna get you back listen
that's him right there but he uh
james is um
he figured out a way to like
and for everything that you got on him
he figures out the loophole by next year
like that one foot shot just became from
people you just start picking up his
footwork too good and then he came with
a one foot three
yeah and people thought it was a joke
during the summer and it was
not a joke he started shooting it in the
game it's unbelievable somebody that got
the balls to shoot a one foot floater
three
yeah you know it's crazy off a step back
what about um someone who you feel like
you had the your biggest personal rival
on the court somebody who you know maybe
there was a little personal tension
where you know maybe you guys went to
war so much that it kind of felt like
you know there was there was like some
serious energy at a certain point in
your career whenever you would step on
the court with someone
i ain't never really had nobody go like
really
bad blood with me i feel like there was
a wasn't there a time you got in trouble
for trying to go into the locker room to
fight somebody after a game oh nercus
nurkich yeah that's
he was doing the nba talk and i wasn't i
wasn't trying to get the on the court
tech but it was like
it was just we ended up having a
conversation afterwards uh
um i believe i forgot who
who set it up for us but i ended up
talking to him but i think the next time
we played or some [ __ ] we even squashed
it but it was uh
i felt like some of the [ __ ] he was
doing and one of the things he said it
was like bro there's a slo-mo replay
like
you realize my daughter somebody on the
street might really think this is how
this go like yeah they might think they
really finna get this off and i'm
letting you know bro we don't get that
off like
i told him when i was coming to the
locker room i told him on the court and
i think everybody thought because we won
i just was like gonna let it go
and i took off and went through the back
and you know what's crazy is they made
it a big thing like i walked over there
and people was like holding me back and
all this other [ __ ] and it wasn't
bro like i knew how to get there through
this
i went through the back locker room and
everything to where i just popped up and
i'm at this locker room g and i'm like
come out come out here and have a
conversation with me dude for real i
don't even know if i was gonna fight him
or not all right
yeah we gotta have a talk bro cause
y'all just
this nba [ __ ] is y'all going too far bro
and i don't know
i don't know where we at like
you can't tell me it's on deck like that
and then
i get out the uber and you right there
bro cause once it's on deck it's on deck
so it's like i'm not you know what i'm
saying i don't know how to do that every
time somebody told me it's on site it
was really on site that's real [ __ ] and
i'm fighting for you know what i'm
saying i'm not really just this ain't no
the teacher gonna break it up fight you
know what i'm saying it's like i haven't
been in a fight that took two minutes
long like you have been fight check two
minutes bro it's the longest [ __ ] in the
world
two minutes is a long fight a long
streak
if you're fighting for 20 seconds it
feels it feels free
yeah but it's usually a fight nobody
helping yeah yeah it's like if ain't
nobody help ain't nobody here to break
two minutes it's a very long fight so
that's what i'm thinking of i'm thinking
more like that like bro if we pop out in
a club what i'm supposed to just act
like we cool now like after you say some
[ __ ] like that like you do some [ __ ]
like that like he's
he was just like two i don't know it was
too like whatever deal with it i'm like
bro ain't no deal with it like yeah i
know and then he's like saying a
different language and threw a couple of
you know threw a couple of american
curse words at me i'm sweaty i ain't
going for that yeah i don't like it
that's all i ran back there but i ain't
never had nobody that i'm like looking
for in the league like right right right
i've never had nothing like that um i
just think he just took it a little too
far when he shouldered me who do you
think is the most underrated player that
you ever
share the court with in the nba just
someone who doesn't get enough love
enough flowers for how good they are or
what they bring to the game
j.r smith
j.r
j.r smith i think uh
at one point i even
told j.r he was
like he was talking to me like i'm like
bro i don't know who you think i am bro
but i used to play with you on the video
games oh for sure on 2k with with the
nuggets and with the hornets
like he was at one point though it was
like but that's what i mean about the
league like
i remember when he was on the nuggets he
was having like
like i think he had a 50-point game yeah
yeah like he was
he's like i said when he when jail is
hot
it's automatic but it was like because
so many people put him into that
category of like he's got to be hot he's
streaky he's right
he's got behavior problems it's like bro
he was 18 y'all put him in the league
and gave him some money
he's gonna make like he had to grow up
in front of everybody in front of
everyone's eyes i'm like bro that sucks
and now y'all putting him in a weird
role y'all talking about my dog like at
one point j.r was talking to me i'm like
bro you are j.r smith i don't know what
the [ __ ] you talking about right now
you're j.r smith don't forget that yeah
like i don't know what you want right
now i used to play video games with you
fam like not
shoulder-to-shoulder [ __ ] like
i'm going on the fantasy draft to make
sure i got j.r smith on my roster
like you not gonna talk to me like that
bro you gonna talk to me like you j.r
smith yeah i think you gonna teach me
[ __ ] that j.r smith should be teaching
me and you gonna walk first like you
know what i'm saying like that's how i
felt about jr cause it's like bro y'all
like even went on that team it was like
people didn't understand i was still 20
21 year old that was like i went from
being at georgia tech
lockout hidden i'm at chicago i'm really
i'm in chicago just kicking it i got the
homies we
i got ready for the for the league [ __ ]
literally just playing with my homies
every day we just playing ball in the
gym
we're doing our own sprint drills yeah i
wasn't paying a train or nothing it was
just going for blood playing ball every
day with them talking [ __ ] so it was
like bro i went from that to
mello is my teammate amari's my teammate
uh
tyson baron davis mike bibby i'm looking
around like [ __ ] i'm like don't
forget my baby was on that team before
j.r smith you just came from china to
play on my team like i'm like this man
on my team bro
[Music]
but i also think like oh no he's still
everybody's favorite i just think people
love him yeah for sure
but under appreciated and undervalued as
a player as a player there's no reason
he should have never touched in a
hundred million dollar contract that's
what i mean like yeah we're not gonna
sit here
and
like it's just other players that got
paid just because they were a good guy
and i didn't like that there were some
players that got guys what was that one
weird year where everyone got paid that
shouldn't have gotten paid it was just
timing of the the negotiations it was it
was the year the knockout year uh the
lockout year happened we had to put that
new uh cba in place what's the name of
that dude that got paid that when it was
on the lakers lil dan got paid but he
actually was solid uh but there was the
white dude
that got super paid
who ended up
was it ma it wasn't moderate timing very
much he's got 70. yeah it was mozgov
yeah he didn't get super paid for no
reason though mozzie was serving chips
oh yeah i mean listen lose him they
didn't expect he had a great finals they
didn't use him after that yeah you know
what i'm saying so it did make him the
next year probably did look like he
wasn't [ __ ] yeah no but he had a great
finals if not used properly everybody in
the league looks like [ __ ]
okay what about this what would you
is there anything
that you would say you like your biggest
regret about your career
biggest regret
there was one point that uh
they was bringing me in the uh office
with the knicks and
mike woodson
was basically telling me
i need you to play two guard
like i need you to for what this team
needs to be
and no disrespect to raymond felton who
at the time was running the ball club
for me to grow into what i felt like i
was gonna become like i always felt like
like i wanted to be jason kidd but i
always felt like i was penny i'm like
i'm penny hardaway like i'm the big
point guard that is going to do [ __ ]
[ __ ] that looks like a two guard at
times but i just don't want to play two
guard i'd much rather play point and
y'all go get me somebody that wants to
shoot it every time but i don't want
like
somebody that's like trying to figure it
out like i want to
a [ __ ] i want a complete [ __ ]
that too like right
like people didn't understand why i
loved buddy hill so much and why he
played so well when i was there
buddy healed is what i'm talking about
when i say a complete [ __ ] and not an
[ __ ] with how he takes direction or
anything like that but an [ __ ] in the
regard that
i could look you in the eye buddy and
say do not shoot this shot i don't care
how open it is
don't shoot this shot
when i throw it to him if a [ __ ]
ain't in his face all over him he's
shooting he's shooting it yeah
because no matter no amount of pressure
no side bet it ain't nothing that could
go on in his mind that make him feel
like he's about to miss this shot
he is completely
invested in saying i've never missed a
shot in my life
and i love it because you need a
[ __ ] like that that's a
superpower to be able to shoot an air
ball shoot it off the glass and then
come down and shoot all night short
memory man unbelievable yeah while
everybody figure out what they gonna do
when they see oh
oh
oh why are you shooting that everybody
got everything to say
you come down and get that he's shooting
four out of four every time i throw it
to him it was like i wanted that and i
want it to be penny and i had that
moment in that locker room
with woody i could have just i felt like
i should have just tore up the locker
room when i got traded i watched melo
tear up the locker room just throw
chairs and do all the [ __ ] [ __ ] and i
was like
that's what i should have did and i
should have said trade me
wow
trade me cause i'm not playing two
i play point this is how i play this is
how you get the most out of me if you
take me out of that and i never did this
other [ __ ] before i could i become
something else
and in my mind i was trying to hope like
i was just gonna grow into this player
that you know what i'm saying like maybe
i play point guard at the end of the
game now but i start off playing two
guard and i'm averaging more like maybe
it could work out i'm trying to like
dive into it and it just felt like all
right bro y'all just switched me to a
three and d guy and now i just got less
responsibility but you had a great
career i mean listen you had a great
career for sure but you asked me what i
would regret no i i regret doing that
because i felt you might have had a
different path i just wanted to play
point guard bro like even though we won
a championship that's what i wanted to
do that's not how i wanted to do it
last thing uh
jordan or lebron who's the goat jordan
yeah
okay
like i said bro you buy my dog you know
this though be a brave video arguments
about this though does he take that does
he like is he conscientious about that
[ __ ] laughs at that [ __ ] bro he's like i
feel like he is in the conversation why
the [ __ ] does i mean i feel like he is
the conversation he's getting compared
to michael jordan though we having real
life arguments in barbershops about
who's better between him and mike so let
me ask you this though he gonna get bad
for he don't get mad bro that's what i'm
saying about braun that's raw as [ __ ] to
me cause me personally i would be like
mike gotta play me one-on-one [ __ ] all
that we streaming this [ __ ] right right
right let's listen cause for real for
real i low-key thing mike's so
competitive bro mike could come out of
retirement right now to play bro and do
one hell yeah and take a l
calm down maybe take a serious though
you gotta you ac mike who for a while i
i i don't need to see it
right now lebron versus mike right now
dog do you know how mike jordan you
ain't never seen it though you've never
seen mike i've seen michael jordan in
person no you've never seen him just
sitting down and just get up in his
street clothes
no i've heard about it though he does it
all the time bro and every time you
think like this thing can't dunk no more
but don't you think lebron has had
the level of competition has been a lot
more insane for lebron are you being
serious right now very much so
you're being dead serious bro okay
you're being dead serious right now do
you know what michael jordan had to deal
with bro
we can go over his finals opponents and
go over lebron's finals opponents and
you tell me who had the tougher teams
you tell me who lost
okay that's fair
but he also played
the trailblazers
he played what was wrong with the
trailblazers i mean the trailblazers
ain't they have no secrets
they have a super team
lebron had to play it's a dick sucking
statement lebron had the jesus christ
this is only a statement that a retired
iman shepherd can could make
i'm just saying we talking
about it alright so listen so lebron had
to go through and oh what in o5 he had
to play
peak it was o7 rather was it 0.705 you
went to the finals against the spurs
he's been up quite a few times well the
first time he went against the spurs
that was the first kind of
incarnation of
the spurs dynasty before kauai right so
that's like peak mining so you think
mike and scotty wasn't going to blow
that out we just beat the spurs 4-0 and
sent them the [ __ ] home i don't know man
we just shook pop hand like a great guy
i mean
the jazz took the the bulls i think i
think y'all the cavaliers would have
swept the jazz
first we're not talking about the
cavaliers but the booze didn't sweep the
jazz
it was it was it was a serious series we
got lebron james we could match up with
the jazz
i could get over a screen we could deal
with john
that he played a thunder team with kevin
durant russell westbrook and james
harden in the finals
we could have matched up with that with
the bulls fam
think about it we got ron harper six six
i like that who was gonna guard mike on
that thunder team
it wasn't gonna be kd he don't want to
do it yeah who was gonna guard mike
what i'm saying who was gonna guard him
so you think that because scotty p was
gonna guard him you think scotty p was
on guard kd mike was defensive team he
was gonna take russ who we gotta deal
with james harden off the bench sixth
man okay see i'm saying who gonna deal
with cool coach when he come off the
bench at 6 11.
we coming to the party bro
so you mean to tell me you oh he's so
cute you think that's so cute give me
something
you need something you think the bulls
had tougher competition in the finals
than what i'm saying lebron
violate the bulls bro do not compare
these new teams to them bulls bro i
don't think y'all remember how them
bulls played listen i don't think y'all
remember i
watched don't think
i got to the nba i got to the nba
watching these [ __ ] they wasn't
playing with these people they're not
going to play none of these games none
of them you don't remember when gary
payton was giving us a hard time what's
phil dude hey scotty
deal with this man 94 feet
i like it i like how he speaks as as as
a wii perspective for with the bulls
what you mean we're not good we never
win we not we not having it yeah
it's got to be dope to see the bulls be
good again right yeah we wrote oh
they're
the wii we call the sale right now and
speaking of we the cavaliers are cold
again
mobley's abs are doing a great job
moby's but that's not we oh so okay so
once you're not a cavalier for life
you're watching i'm a cavalier within
the 16 team
i'm i don't know these new guys i feel
like you're like i don't go to war with
them okay because i feel like cleveland
will always look at you as like wanted
like a like cleveland
you said the cavs though see so no they
traded some they traded chum yeah 2016
cavs love them
everybody else [ __ ]
there it is man
big time bulls guy oh man hey uh do you
think my sons have a shot at the chip
this year
the sons yeah
i don't know man last year was y'all yo
it was our chance right
it's gonna be tough this year i mean
we've been doing all right
there's nothing about y'all doing all
right it's about if them who's your pick
off the top of your head right now who's
your pick to be in the finals two teams
l.a
lakers or clippers got to ask obviously
it's the lakers right
or is it the clippers kawaii comes back
maybe they make something happen
yeah the lake show and
every time people do that to me when
they say the lakers are clippers it
always throws me off it throws me off
too so i was thinking i just happened so
when you said that i had to think about
the clifford's roster for a second
just to make sure i wasn't completely
leaving them out but no they're not
gonna i don't feel like they got it
it'll be either
the lakers and the bulls
or
maybe i just wanted to be the lakers in
the bulls but it's going to be
i don't really like a lot of teams in
the east right now it ain't that they're
not good i just don't like them
yeah i don't like i mean i hear you i
just don't like my eyes no i hear you to
even say that to foreshadowing because
everyone we all thought the nets would
have been the team but obviously
it's not that's not the nest yet right
kyrie chilling
y'all got to remember that man ain't
there
mama that go that man that man at home
right now they always say kyrie and i i
think kyrie to me is like as far as like
handles and just skill wise is probably
top five ever
that but but for sure
would you would you put them up there
yeah i mean who else is up there ain't a
lot of [ __ ] up there i think
he's got the best handles i've ever seen
yeah better we got who we got uh him
jamal crawford
uh
alan
i think i think when i watch when i
watch kyrie play
and it's in slow motion and it looks
like art like when you see kyrie in slow
motion in his bag
it's like watching art dude it's like oh
dude it's the craziest [ __ ] but it's
only like a couple of a few of those put
in there yeah putting that many guys
ain't that many guys with a nasty handle
like
everybody just got a handle for what
they need to score like kyrie got a
handle that it's like if you need him to
dribble out the clock that's crazy ain't
nobody touching that ball uh so your
project's coming out top of your
hopefully yeah man this car ain't stolen
is your is wifey going to be on the
project she's not on the project you
know she's done with music she's just
done
done with features done with it all
i i can't speak for i'm saying i'm
hoping that the energy is stays positive
and she continues because i don't want
her to stop you know what i'm saying but
i'm off i feel like she's so talented
and like somehow still hasn't even met
her peak yet but that's the issue that's
why she wanted to stop because it's like
um whatever that wall is she doesn't
understand the wall and it's like now
if it's going to like
hurt her mentally
it's not worth dealing with i'm saying
she's like i've been doing that for so
long and it hasn't brought me the
happiness i need
and before it becomes a point where
she doesn't love music
or the effect like you said if it
affects your happiness in a negative
that's what i'm saying though but it's
like peace some of that is like
i want to continue to love music and it
becomes now i think of music as a game
maybe and it's yeah it's like it becomes
work or like i got to figure out
how to do this or how to she wants it to
be like she goes to the studio and then
just be carefree again yeah and just
making music and singing with a heart
and it ain't all this thought like you
don't want to come out in the label
already like yeah well could you think
you could say this and it's like
yeah all that after a while it's like i
can't imagine 15 years of somebody
keeping me in a box and trying to oh
this is hot right now you should follow
behind this girl and it's like dog like
i just want to do my thing and turn my
album in y'all put the money behind it
go out to them let me shoot my videos
let me go do my show that's how it and
it's like once they're done yeah once
it's not that harmony like i can
understand that for her doing it for so
long it's like it got to be a headache
so i get it but i just hope that and so
before she comes back because she's
incredible you know what i'm saying like
i i spend that album before i go to
sleep i'm saying i'm still a fan even
though i'm a husband you know what i'm
saying so it's like
i still want her to come back so i don't
you know what i'm saying put too much
pressure on anything we just sort of let
it happen let the energy happen i hope
she comes back well listen the album
hopefully we get it soon and y'all gonna
get that uh um
hey hopefully we see you on a basketball
court again
yeah it's very possible
i feel like the lakers is a very very
serious candidate to bring iman trumper
back to the league it would make sense
you have so many friends on the team you
bring a set of skills that they need
it's crazy sometimes i'll be feeling
like i'll be like man after a while they
just gonna have me sit there and they
don't want me to be an announcer or some
[ __ ] bro cause i'm like [ __ ]
wanna talk about it with me so much i'm
like can i put one thing into the world
i'd like to see in the next five years i
want to see you and j.r smith do a
podcast together
oh that was gonna happen eventually
anyway not an actual like
the
you
mean
the smoke is or
yeah oh that'd be must-see tv in fact if
you guys were living in the same city
and you guys could do a podcast once a
week once a month swish i ain't doing
[ __ ] that is i'm telling you that is a
bag that is swiss i ain't doing [ __ ] boy
you guys better go tap in with bill
simmons at the ring or somebody and they
would that is the that is the pod the
the iman and and swish
podcasts will you guys just talk [ __ ]
what
i'm actually doing the podcast my
podcast is uh is coming so that's coming
yeah yeah it's with me and my brother
though okay um but
me and my brother is probably uh
that's probably gonna be y'all best look
at barbershop talk okay because my
brother is like he's like you like he
plays the fan
the fan uh card but he like it's like
serious oh yeah listen man it's like no
[ __ ] you like it's like that
i am extremely invested in sports i
gamble every [ __ ] day i love i have
the league pass
i do i got to say that too though cause
i talk [ __ ] about fans that go out of
their way and say a lot of [ __ ] but it's
like without these fans talking [ __ ] and
creating the energy a lot of the
basketball that we play ain't the same
like you need them hecklers you need it
like
it's all part of it it all adds to the
energy it's all good like for 48 minutes
hate me bro yeah for 48 minutes y'all
can hate me say anything i almost got
into it last year i almost fought uh one
of patrick beverly's friends in phoenix
because i was like down in the that's
not smart well no i was [ __ ]
shit-faced and this was this was the
game
this is the game when when uh patrick
beverly like cheap shot of the [ __ ] out
of chris paul you remember that oh [ __ ]
and i was like
[ __ ] pat beverly
and i'm [ __ ] like black out you know
my son's having me good in 11 years so
i'm just like excited to be at a western
conference final game
and the guy turns around and say hey
that's my bro watch your mouth
and i was like
mind you this guy's by himself i'm in
arizona with a bunch of my essay homies
i said hey
bro
you know where the [ __ ] you're at
you're in [ __ ] phoenix this isn't
[ __ ] layers sugar where the [ __ ]
you're from pat bat
i
i was drunk i was drunk it was about it
things got dicey you know what i'm
saying but hey hey i appreciate it
i know i i was i was feeling myself he
said it though he said i was lit i went
for it i went for it for sure
oh you wanna freestyle are we doing the
freestyle oh they usually rap when they
come let's [ __ ] go man
hey i did not know we were doing a yo
this is a treat
this is a treat
let's do this dude what beat you
any beat you want we'll get you some
more nozzles
now's an easy essence
well listen there is a nazi record
called essence that was nominated
i'm gonna go get us two waters before
you wrap perfect all right